they want you to take this graph and
show that it is monotonically decreasing
in this domain X is greater than minus 1
okay so your first challenge is to
remember what on earth is monotonically
decreasing me right so your clues from
them 10 10 which means one so
monotonically decreasing means it's in
yeah 11 points in monotone means you're
always doing the same thing right so
always decreasing it's always going down
okay so if you want to share this
something's always going down apart from
graph here which you could do but it
wouldn't be a sufficient proof for this
kind of question you need to go to
calculus that's why we've in the
learning right ok so this it's a it's
written as a fraction of 0 which is kind
of gross so let me rewrite it like this
so you can see this is chain rule to
differentiate it ok let's work out do I
DX let's work out the gradient function
what I do
okay so wait wait list goes to the
outside first to bring the power down
okay then reduce the power by 1 which is
minus 40 chart okay and then one that
was the outside what's the rest of
channel the inside which in this case
the druid of the inside function is just
one so actually I'm done okay so just to
put that anymore yeah what we're
normally used to that minus four right
that power doesn't apply to this number
it only applies to that country's okay
so you've got minus 3 on IC x plus 1 to
the power 4 okay so there's a derivative
now if we wanted to monotonically
decreasing or I want to show is this
thing is always negative in the domain
that I'm interested in is a HS this
thing is always negative how do you go
about doing that now the first the first
instinct is to sub some point in okay
then that's fine to verify the you're
correct okay because you put some in a
Mueller oh yeah sure enough anything you
put in in this domain it'll be negative
you're happy right I in fact anything
you put in into the left of this domain
is also ok now we're going to get it
that in a second why that's important I
black just saw the inputs not enough
it's not enough we talked about this
before right like in maths by in life
there are multiple methods of proof some
better than others some valid and some
not valid right so what you're trying to
do is prove by example why does it work
why is it for by example valid method
why isn't it why can't i just say for
instance take like five points or ten
points or 50 points sure they've all got
negative gradient and say well I'm go
home and I'm happy yeah that's right I
want to prove for Walter right this
inequality represents an infinite number
of lovers okay so 5 55 billion won't be
enough okay so I got to do something
else I've got to employ some logic so
what am I going to do I look at this
thing down here before okay the four
turns out to be critical okay um another
way of writing is it's something to the
power of 2 to the power of two okay so
it'll be two square really it's going to
be okay now why would that be
significant why is it important to
square yeah say it again all right yes
it is an even function however that's
you can get even functions which will be
negative as well okay so they even this
inclusive okay that's what we're getting
at right so not only is a square
function um even okay it's going to have
that kind of symmetry but it's always
going to be positive right whatever
numbers you're throwing their the
exception of minus one you're going to
get a positive number so here is what i
would say i would say X plus 1 or
actually wish we start I'm going to say
that this is greater than or equal to
sine of bread and 0 for X government are
you happy with that statement cuz it's a
square right by the way I have to say
this because otherwise if I put minus 1
in i get 0 which is not positive it's
not anything to do with alone yeah
that's true um no Matt that's
self-evidently true in fact by the way
we will and go into this in more detail
in atopic court either qualities which
has the qualities okay but this is
something years no squares a positive
okay all right now therefore I can go
from here to this line over here now
what do I do I'm going to take the
reciprocal of both sides
I'd be careful here reciprocal of this
it's not what I of 0 right in this case
I'm saying what if I got something
positive if you take one and you divided
by a positive number you're still going
to get a positive number right so Kira
quality still holds you happy on that
now to get to what I'm actually
interested in i'm going to multiply 1-3
you guys know when you multiply both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number what happens the sign changes
direction okay so that's all i get minus
agree over that that is negative as I'm
interested in okay so therefore dy/dx is
less than zero for the given domain
sorry however and so your conclusion is
therefore it's monotonically decreasing
yeah question exactly yeah yeah okay um
I think you probably would be you might
be able to get better I think this is
what too much too much yeah it's a 32 I
think it before we could get away with
that because if you're provided number
when your back is good and I'm until you
differentiate it properly okay because
really what we're looking at is for you
to get to the derivative and get that
monotonically increasing or decreasing
it's a property of the gradient function
okay so that's sort of where your main
work is and whether you do it
algebraically or graphically I don't
think it matters too much okay which
part
oh yeah okay so this is just it's just a
more rigorous website so one is mom's
you just take the negative out and say
that since a constant that we changed
yeah you can say it but it's always us
mathematicians who doesn't like the
words right so yeah the strength of your
argument starts to defray them in this
when you don't have you just have the
equations like look at this this is you
don't need to argue it it stands for
itself